new in theaters this weekend Sonic the
Hedgehog and the photograph what will
you see this is your weekend ticket
I'm Sonic a little ball of super energy
in an extremely handsome package on my
planet people were always after my
powers so I came to yours finally coming
to the big screen excluding his wreck-it
Ralph cameo is Sonic the Hedgehog when a
blue hedgehog named Sonic teleports from
another world he draws the attention of
dr. Robotnik with his ability - gotta go
fast now sonic must team up with the
local sheriff to understand this strange
new world and to obey the doctors many
contraptions and weapons this movie is
for you if you're looking for a movie
for the whole family this weekend you're
excited for some long overdue Jim Carrey
comedy or if you're a Sonic fan so deep
in the lore you know Sonic's favorite
food I keep reading her words don't you
want more than this would you know more
do you want my mother wasn't very good
at love what if I'm just like her how
are you supposed to know if you want to
spend forever with someone I want to try
to be together it's not practical I'm
not trying to be practical want to be
with you Pamela Keith Stanfield is busy
oh sorry
when a young photographer is faced with
being vulnerable by a blossoming
relationship she finds new confidence
when she finds a photo of her mother and
delves into her past now they find
themselves looking at a past for advice
and clarity for their future this movie
is for you if a romance movie is what
you seek you're looking for a good
Valentine's Day date movie or if you're
trying to keep up with all the like
Keith Stanfield movies let's see I saw
uncut gems knives out get out sorry to
bother you
oh I haven't seen it Lana that is your
weekend ticket well you see and check
back next week for Brahms the boy too